Infamous Splash Mountain got on the ride  everything was going good we were now  screaming and having a good time  laughing and as soon as the the picture  part came we decided to do the hands up  pose like oh we were going down and  honestly that wasn't the best thing to  do I heard her like say oh my gosh like  from the corner of my eyes I could like  see her like bring her arms down and  like hug herself and I'm just like did  that just happen like I knew what  happened but I didn't want to believe it  okay that's the Rival slowing down I was  like what happened she's like my top  went down so when we were waiting for  the ride to slow down and to stop and  you know like the little bars and stuff  had to come out like she was about to  lift the bars of herself if it was  possible we have to hurry up and get out  before anyone else got us you know kids  are fast and we like rushed to like the  little monitors and that's basically  what was on the Monitor and it was so